when the pandemics shut down tourism
around the world it brought hard times
for the travel industry especially in
developing countries like thailand but
one woman who's a conservationist and
the founder of thailand's elephant
nature park saw an opportunity elizabeth
palmer shows us how she was able to give
more elephants a better life she would
take me like childer loves elephants
i'm sorry about her she's a big bossy
and they love her right back
she's the founder of thailand's oldest
elephant sanctuary she like
what's she saying to you
before covid it was a magnet for foreign
tourists who paid to see these animals
roaming free
but the pandemic wiped out both tourism
and the money it brought in
for two years the only visitors have
been a few volunteers like aj hill from
california determined to help childert's
sanctuary as a humane alternative to
cruel elephant
the way that they have to train the
elephants is they they like abuse them
they start up they put nails in their
ears and they chain them up so they
can't move anywhere it's just it's
upsetting
child's animals are all elderly formerly
abused or unwell so looking after them
is expensive she's got cancer this one
get cancer
kovet dealt a double whammy to lack
suddenly she was dealing with a lot less
money
and many more mouths to feed
30 extra animals were dropped off here
during the pandemic by owners who could
no longer afford them
they just left them here they just left
them here yes
so chiller added them to the family and
made sure somehow that the food wouldn't
run short
in the kitchen it's all hands on deck
right down to the littlest
the sanctuary grew some of its own food
more came from local farmers and upward
of a million dollars rolled in from
donors especially in the united states
covet has has been
a disaster in many ways but you said for
you it's brought something good yeah
kobe brought also
positive to elephant living in thailand
[Music]
specifically it brought a lull in mass
elephant tourism
and tyler spotted an opportunity
on the property next door
elephants used to perform for up to 2
000 tourists a day
but when the tour buses stopped coming
and the elephant riding saddle sat idle
chilert convinced the owners to take off
the chains and turn this place into a
sanctuary too
when we visited tom the vet was dodging
a very protective mom
to dab ointment on her two-day-old baby
he may not grow up in the wild but
thanks to lek chyler none of these
animals will have to do tricks in a
circus
[Music]
like her own elephants they'll be free
to roam in a protected home
for cbs mornings elizabeth palmer chiang
mai thailand
such beautiful animals the only trick i
need is them fording that river there uh
just gorgeous stuff liz bomber nice
piece